all right 10 seconds until kickoff cube
fanatics 93 gladiators are competing aah
war zone raided 1812 average rating time
handicap 30 minutes game 1 against mr.
daybreak get this little ticker over
here
let's go ticker a non mover to start off
uh-huh
aah this is worse than a loss isn't it
that's no quit you're exaggerating let's
go elsewhere actually let's not let's
pre move that the fear that c5 move fear
it aah
we got action no there might be Bishop
g5 Oh devastating with that beat I'll be
very devastating don't get devastated so
early like that 30 seconds this game
could be over I'm actually ready to just
throw my queen out here and played there
just for fun Queen a5 to e1 a spike
check I'm gonna do it are they watching
the stream she's come back home anything
anything at all this game is not gonna
end okay tricky Knights land just grab
stuff just grab a pond throw a bishop
here this game is not gonna end they're
gonna see that they are gonna see it
shags wants to be made I can't castle
watch me lose this one I actually had to
build a concern they're back to
tournament that was ugly kitchen sink a
kitchen sink them mini chests that was
poorly calculated by the way I was
actually fearing for me right there for
a second or two okay we got checks and
we got that clean running wild she's
she's running wild hang on Knight f4
uh-oh
let's castle grab that bishop Oh grab
this pine hit the Queen weasel around a
g3 be a wheeze ler I'll give a check
right here silly
I'll still do it right here right here
right here now that's like really close
to me Bishop here Queen can't feel
comfortable can she
that Knight can't go anywhere this pawn
is stuck the Knights gonna kill this guy
let's take here first right here I just
want to check on G 300 pins get ready to
hit the rook it's pinned Oh over here go
after the King get out of there and then
pin it spin now grab it how much time
I'm on the Queen I should have taken the
night maybe let's go after them again
let's come here oh yeah
light squares light squares light
squares I want to get to c6 or b2 Beach
are now b7 ah check and then mate b7
light square weaknesses back to
tournament six six six six four threes
two Benko G I got to play against the BG
mr. B G alright mr. B G is well aware
well aware of the fish that I will of
the the bait
there's the pole here's the night
crawler let's get developed
okay I don't know where I'm going with
that night oh I got the light square
bishop I got that light square bishop oh
I can see clearly now there's a song
lyric there's a psalm lyric for you I
could see clearly now the light square
bishop is gone is that what they say
let's go night night f5b wait come on
Mouse get developed here be a developer
no no no no no no if that Knight moves
what happens I want to keep my rook
active he's silly my rook is not silly
I'm on this twice he has to move I think
it can't be good because I get this pawn
uh-oh Forks tricky Forks around every
corner
hang on I feel like I'm really missing
something right there okay let's just
develop let's watch over this my rook is
ready to be trapped no no no no no no
right here that's where you want to be
go after the beep on what's the clock
situation okay decent on-time decent on
time grab here grab here grab here and
then back up before you lose your rug I
don't want a castle right here is where
you belong King right in the center no
don't you do don't you dare do that
tricky night come on King get out of
there rope let's trade oh they missed it
pal resign they can resign give me that
night get rid of the tricky night and
everything is gonna be okay
move that pawn over here time time time
watch out for stalemate over here right
here they're done they're down a time
okay 17 12 12 12 max let's go max d4
Knight c3 okay let's grab here trap that
Queen maybe no it's the it's the non
trap variation know what that means they
here mmm its card this and well okay
let's go here can take with the knight
get a four tricky Forks tricky forks
let's go I don't want I don't want this
night to it'll be traded I want to I
think the bishop would be too happy if
that happened I don't want their Bishop
to be happy take care and then man this
Queen is too active
she's definitely too active right here
have the rooks come off no I'm on the
Queen first to avoid this Oh
Knight right here that's juicy it's a
juicy square I'm on the bishop uh-oh
uh-oh
King side damage King side damage we
officially have some King side damage
going on here let's throw a check in
just for fun but what did that really
accomplish nothing nothing I got to come
here I have to guard this let's come
over here it's safer isn't it I could
give a check on b3 still my Brook is
active rook up and over
b3 a7 the King side is wounded wounded
Kings side now oh the queen is dead
queen is dead 10 seconds go go go go go
give a check come over here give another
check come here pawn push look for mates
right around the corner
check check right here grab that rook
pin it and then push and now take and
get a clean go quickly go quickly come
on Mouse come through here come through
can I get this I'm semi holding my
breath here holding my breath here come
on queeny's watch out for the checkmates
I mean to stalemates I got it
who's holding my breath 34 28 27 20 no
easy wins no no no no I won't see 500
should just take in that pine I'll do it
now I'll just do it now if I mouse
slipped one time I will not no slip
again will I
with a fishing pole and then the night
crawler and then the removal of the
defender coming up next take him
you know he's free and you wanna bite
him no he's not bitten he chased him
away back to tournament not the first
time and maybe not the last be aware be
G again the BG then Koji am I gonna get
that clean no I am NOT I want to get rid
of the LightSquared Bishop though
because oh I wasn't expecting that
it's castled now I don't want to do that
it's queenside castle my bishops gonna
get kicked away or is it if it gets
kicked I go C's I go back to c2 maybe I
could do this I should probably do this
okay let's come back Bishop here Oh
clean here no let's do this we're gonna
oh I just dropped my broke please don't
take my rook okay I got this
in-betweener though I'm a mom Queen oh
it's dangerous it's definitely dangerous
I don't know why I did that move it's
come here but never clean trade we are
gonna have a clean trade checks tricky
checks go after this pawn are they gonna
suspect it probably King there oh I want
to go after this pond now I need a king
position where's my king position they
could get my pawn
they got my pawn I got their pond Oh
who's better who's better
uh-oh I want to push my pawns or maybe I
don't
maybe I do let's give a check give a
check the king is having to go elsewhere
my bishops are guarding all of these
squares I think it's uh he's a runner
for a touchdown here isn't he Oh check
okay they're gonna take that I gotta win
this now
ah just can't be easy no I can't
post up right here nice and cozy look
for the cozy
squares here is that came close to mated
get out of there bishop oh that's not
stalemate is it let's come here right
here let's grab that pond let's try it
again
oh oh they're down on time back
determine fifty three forty two forty
two many chess again whoa okay let's go
see five
let's roll here let's get that pine
let's go with this I don't want to get
pushed around so easily and it might be
happening easily oh I just got my queen
Oh take it oh that's a bad mouse lip Wow
she stuck her head out right there for
b6 did you catch that did you catch that
that should have been that shouldn't
happened oh my heart rate shot up you
have no idea right there Wow let's run
home it's safe there isn't it just go
home would you clean its ID safe home
it's safe home that's the only plan
that's the only plot Oh tongue tied
again again get Castle before they take
on their five they have that available
too let's just trade stuff they could
take it again how many times I gonna
miss that for kuru skis give me a fork I
got a fork everybody loves a fork grab
the rook he's more valuable grab here
Queen b6 Queen b6 for the win
wow that was a lovely lovely moon if
I've ever seen one that was as lovely as
a cat's right there Oh checks push that
part to Victory Lane hang on okay now
it's okay let's give check here and then
play here take that you know you want to
take that are they gonna take that okay
they took that I got the knife though
pac-man mode just gobble them up don't
let any time come off of your clock
Oh check right here don't run into
stalemate please just push this there's
got to be an easier way grab here and
then there now they're down to Donna
time what do we got 70 69 56 I'm in 3rd
17 minutes remaining Jonathan II for for
the win
French don't mouse slip
don't you dare Mouse slip hang on to
your queen
Queenie - Queenie - let's pin a night
we're gonna have a bloodbath right here
on e4 a lot of pieces are about to die
right there okay we're a castle on
opposite sides
let's chop oh wait a second there might
be no no no there might be sneaky stuff
here sneaky stuff sneaky stuff oh this
can't be good can it right here I should
just take in the rook take the rook can
I get a quick me are they gonna miss it
they're not gonna miss that oh that was
check ah there I should just take in the
rug they got a time edge where did my
advantage go down the tubes Oh down the
tubes grab a pond he was free take free
stuff I want this pond that's why I'm
not taking here let's oh there's another
free one free pieces everywhere it's
still free let's take care to check
where does that mean that part could
still be taken it's taking this time ah
get out of there Bishop I want to get my
rook here ah that's not gonna happen
though Forks I'm setting myself out for
4 is 10 seconds I'm have any time
where's my time oh they're gonna kill my
bishop they're gonna kill my bishop
they're gonna come my pawn trades trades
trades I can't go there I got the rook I
don't have any time though where is my
time push my parm
1 1887 72 oh they're designer 11 games
in 4 first first has 11 second has nine
games in right there ah man I should
take in the rook white I take that rook
Oh dark square weaknesses III Queen b6
is actually okay now in that position
it's quite all right when there's not a
pawn on c5 you could play your Queen to
b6 it'll be okay I promise I promise you
it'll be okay
b5 not so fast
let's baby step it let's do that I don't
want that night in here
don't you dare Oh grab a knight and hit
a fork that was a fork if I have ever
seen a fork that was a fork right there
oh okay this is still alright
still okay push this Knight around keep
pushing keep pushing he's passed this is
a majority keep going with it keep going
keep going Knight position right here
would have been better getting a fork
right here let's try it again
let's go chickpea 9 tricky 93 he has
landed successfully right there
successful landing check we got one pig
one pig on the second looking for
another what's better than one it's two
pigs
unavoidable main two no one back two
chairmen one 1890 8776 13 minutes and
change a lot of catching up to do
somebody has to knock off that guy cab
am I gonna get paired up with him
that'll be a big one that'll be a big
one right there he's maybe about ready
to win too so what do you do when that's
the story what do you do
can you just Castle kingside please
please you know you just want a Castle
kingside castle darn it
they're onto my tricks let's do that
Knight here is probably good no let's
take a look
take this pond please give me some play
on the G file take the Queen or I get
here okay they did that night right
there okay uh come over here get in see
for let's come over here I want to I
want to get to the seventh rank
pigs pigs pigs pigs this Bishop needs to
get out of here so I need to make
progress get that Bishop out of here oh
the king is a fighting piece he's a
fighter
I have pawn block if Bishop check all
right let's go one pig looking for
another another Pig King position where
is the other Pig let's go with this part
Oh something just happened there that
wasn't good let's do this pig over here
where's the mate where does that mean
over here mate in one
no no no back to chairman 158 127 110
Wow 11 minutes and change I only have
ten games in top guy at 13 Anton Anton
squared
I think I'm reading that right a squared
we have here being fancy now b5 is
prevented all right let's get in this
move let's get it in
and now play here and maybe stop Knight
g5 stuff and okay hit that Bishop Bishop
here is probably not good because the
bishop takes pawn but now it's probably
no I'm gonna do this just in case Bishop
takes pawn we're still there I want to
avoid discovered tricks against my king
right there so let's get this up looking
to crunch that Bishop let's do this
instead I don't want him to see the
world that bishops trapped it's a trap
bishop
that's what that means that's what that
means right there silly its recapture
here what they do
oh they I was on pre move right there I
forgot okay oh they took oh they took
over here Wow I completely missed that
oh they missed that let's do this let's
reset this position here I'm losing
track of where I'm at Bishop back here
okay now it's coming back to me here
seen it clearly clean F four more trades
let's just trade Queens kill that night
and look for back rank mate kill both
nights this one's this is a start with
check and then play here make a one
threat or two King here doesn't save it
can't clean the corner right here's me
okay back to turn 1:30 whoa 178 131 27
what do you do
what do you do when somebody has a 40
point lead right you play go for cheap
tricks you gotta be tricky that's your
only chance employ some tricks and hope
they follow alright let's do that and
then this and then guess who can't
Castle black black hand Castle I can't
castle either of a black shouldn't of
Castle that's what I meant
Queen h5 okay let's go each pond you
know you want to contribute
you definitely know you want to
contribute here it's a little scary
night right here he's ready to drop a
bomb or something
woah I'm gonna take and then take again
just take my bishop you know you want to
take that bishop he's juicy take him
he's free if I freakin h8 Bishop h7 no
come on give me mate where's me give me
me pond pushes mate that's me I think
yes it is back to term of one ninety
eight forty eight point lead 15 games in
I only have 12 um all right let's grab
here before my knight gets kicked away
a5
it out too soon ah Queen b6 Oh were they
thinking I was gonna play Queen b6 there
come on
move that night give me that night
meeting to threat mean to h3 doesn't
save it oh you're going into a think
it's a thinker ah okay what can you do
you could back up
you could play here and you could kill
this night kill them ooh I don't know
what I want to do let's come here I want
to push this pawn I think yeah I
definitely want to push that pun let's
go here how's Adelaide here maybe night
here if they give up the light square
Bishop I want to get my queen here
somehow oh they gave up their queen
they resigning back to term at 170 still
a forty eight point lead I mean somebody
has to knock them off and then I have to
play them in I have to win - Derek let's
roll here efore is there any hope there
is hope
well 218 quick resigner 218 190 oh that
was a quick boost seven minutes in
change seven minutes and change that's
what the ticker says the tickers right
here if you're wondering it's right here
man everybody is sniffing out the Queen
c7 line they're sniffing it right out
actually I could have played here bear I
could have still done that I should have
done that move earlier check Forks on
that Bishop that's why I could do this
if the knight blocks no I want the dark
sir bishop I care more about getting the
darker Bishop I got the dark square
bishop you get this pawn I'm on it
bishop here looking for tricky stuff on
f7
I was writing with that pond how do i
drop my bishop okay now let's just do
this I want to develop be a developer
let's trade
I want my king on f7 and all right let's
okay I'll drop that pond I just want to
get developed right here right here the
knight can't move I have a three covered
by my Bishop and actually couldn't move
the rook was defending that I missed
that one all right let's guard my
seventh rank all right let's do this pig
I'm on em - there's a rope check okay
here we go
flight square is needed for them and
they got it 13 seconds I could grab that
pond let's just try for it anyhow I have
trades this game is not gonna end not
gonna end do that you're gonna take
these aren't good Primo's that I'm
running with okay that's a decent one
right here pond push on recapture back
determine 210 238 238 210 17 out of 17 5
minutes and change there's two games at
least two more games can be played maybe
a third I have to keep winning for sure
and I have to win quick can I get it f7
f7 is exactly where I want to be right
here can we get f7 in here I need that
night around he's my he's my worm right
there
he's the worm okay there's not gonna be
anything against the king that Bishop is
a fantastic defender maybe there is let
me let me try a trap is the knight gonna
take here the bishop is actually still
trapped still trapped and I can maybe
get this knight assume they're after
Knight here threatening a fork I'm on
this Knight width check with check an
important detail okay pac-man mode I
want to keep my queen around
get rooks right here let's open this up
what how do i how do I just do that I'm
not sure why
hit that rook it's come here for a
second hang on I gotta get this part
look at how far how do I let it get so
far why did I do that this is scary now
oh it's not scary anymore
okay I just want to get this I just want
to get this here can we please just get
this I have this covered
I have everything covered okay where's
the main gap here where is that me
okay the King is a box tell Bishop check
and then mate or something no I just had
me right there that's me that's me back
to German to 32:58 three minutes and
change there's only one more game for
sure maybe maybe a second but I'm having
to still keep winning ah they're gonna
push d5 and there goes my fun there goes
any thoughts of a quick mate out the
window kill that night or just play to
this square first I want to keep that
pin this has to be uncomfortable all
right take care first if there's a g5
okay we're gonna have a bunch of
exchanges dark-squared bishop can i get
that off not really good
Oh dangerous dangerous stuff okay I got
this bishop right here just do a clean
trade even though my pawns look really
ugly really ugly Knight g3 is happening
pawn push I got to get that night out of
there all right let's get this in and
where's my dice crypt what's my dr.
Bishop doing I want to come over here I
don't want to trade too much no not
there I'm in here oh what's that night
Dillon King up pawn push can I do that
tonne of my knight now they're having
none of it none of it and now that rook
is getting active I didn't really want
to do that I'm close to getting mated I
think okay my bishop is around doing
good things I think man that ponds gonna
be running for a touchdown check can I
get this somehow oh I'm a check you
can't do that if you're in check I'm
barely gonna win this one mate all right
it's not even um I can't even be sure I
could win this one that ponds gonna fall
I need to throw some time burners in
here time burner with check more time
burners more time burners grab this pond
it might just sack the rook for that
I've gotta get that get that night out
of there pawn push oh man this is bad
where the time burners when you need it
time burners time burners come on that's
not even a good time burner where we
have I should come over here
come on run for the hills run for the
hills oh it's a draw - draw - draw - 30
but guess
oh wait a second I might get there oh
please there was no catch in first place
no matter what
there was no catch in first place just
call it just call it they resigned oh
okay I'll be sure dove a second but
there's no catch in that cap cap is up
there with how many points how many too
many too many points you can't catch
them don't even try that's it game over
tournament over second place confetti is
the first you know what three of beefy
3:18 Wow good games oh I was lucky to
even get where I was at because I had
resigner z' and I shouldn't have won
certain games for sure man